ils veulent loin déjà au domaine là
debout
on sait très bien fait à partir de votre
gueule je promenais le chagrin je vaux
personnes raja nous manquera toute la
gamme serge simard aime rouler quelques
kilomètres pour se rendre dans son coin
de paradis avec sa famille il a
travaillé pendant deux ans pour
construire la résidence familiale deux
ans d'efforts envolés en fumée le 2 mars
dernier
on a préféré je suis méchant personnes
et en faire tout tout tout de robert je
t'adore l'hérault je l'entends tout le
matin son fils de 8 ans samuel aperçoit
quelque chose d'inhabituel mai et
athènes de dormir moi je les voyais aux
toilettes là-bas j'ai vu qu'un numéro au
plafond et les tapas plus ma main je
remets tout part en arrière la mort puis
à celle là que j'ai vu assez vite le
buffet cependant l'opinion
il ya aux démarques de saab aurait un
résultat tout sortir ce que faisais tu
veux t'en sortir des choses
arieh auriez chez td a rejeté fini tous
les membres de la famille sont sains et
saufs
six vies sauvées grâce aux garçons la
député de roberval a tenu à souligner sa
vivacité d'esprit c'est pourquoi je
n'aurais samuel simard huit ans en lui
remettant la médaille de l'assemblée
nationale pour son courage et sa
présence d'esprit pour sa bravoure ayant
permis de sauver tous les membres de sa
famille le 2 mars dernier
la remise de cette distinction rend son
papa très fier un traître chirurgie
quand même qui dans sa version ma nuit
chez free roam d'être sauvé avec le
recul je ne le pardonne at elle
mentionné ratio est rare qu'il a châtié
jusque là vachement fier les citoyens de
sainte hedwidge ont été nombreux à
donner des vêtements et d'autres
articles pour venir en aide à la famille
qui a tout perdu lors d'un incendie et
malheureusement elle n'avait pas encore
souscrit à une assurance habitation le
lancement récemment acheté inter
pour se construire une nouvelle maison à
roberval tout en souhaitant retrouver le
plus tôt possible un pied à terre sur
leurs terres familiales ici leur gaubert
radio-canada sainte hedwidge